opinions expressed are for
non-commercial informational purposes
only listeners are cautioned not to rely
on programmed content to treat or
prevent disease but are advised to
consult with a licensed health care
professional where they live for
diagnosis and treatment of dis content
to treat and now the Superstar of
Alternative Health and purveyor of
medical truth Dr Joel
[Music]
wallik hello and welcome to Dead Doctors
Don't Lie Joel wck your host a
veterinarian and physician and I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to die at 75.5 like their
parents and grandparents um here for
kids and baby boomers and seniors who
don't want to be sick and miserable for
the last 15 to 20 years of their life
like their parents and grandparents we
do have lines open give us a call
tollfree 1 8379 2552 again that's
tollfree one8 379
2552 well there's two pieces of news for
this pandemic thing going on the good
news is the rate of new infections and
the rate of deaths is dropping we have
three vaccines out there and there's a
fourth one coming out in the next couple
of days and you know people are getting
careless and and you know throwing off
their mask and stopping using hand
sanitizers and going in big crowds and
all this kind of stuff because the
figures coming out but the experts
Public Health experts are warning about
a fourth phase of this pandemic thing
coming out there'll be another Spike
here because of all the these um um what
should I say premature um changes you
know in in people's behavior and you
know if you just look at what went on
here in the last day for the United
States um let's see here we went up uh
overnight from yesterday was 29,6
66,0 um infections to 29 m321 th000 okay
um 36 infection sections and then deaths
we went up from
525,600 okay so both the deaths and the
numbers of new infections have gone up
but a lower rate than has been because
it's been going up 100,000 new
infections and 3,000 4,000 6,000 new
deaths and stuff like that and so uh
when you look at the numbers all over
the place Florida of course had some
real serious problem s um yesterday they
had 1.9 million um infections and
31,000 dead today uh they had
1,910 thou 11,000 so it went up about
2,000
infections okay and um let's see here
also
the deaths in Florida went up from
30,000 to 31 ,000 okay and so they're
going up not at the same rate that they
were but be careful stay away from all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no gluten you're
still responsible for all four things
that are going to stop this pandemic
number one you have to be able to absorb
nutrients so you got to stay away from
gluten or wheat butter o so you can
really efficiently absorb all the
nutrients necessary uh for your body to
maintain repair itself and support the
immune system and number two you have to
supplement you cannot get everything you
need just by eating well any doctor who
tells you that should be put in jail
okay that is not true okay you cannot
get everything you need by eating well
minerals for instance you need 60
essential minerals for everything to
work in your body and nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform like
around the coast of your Earth they Cur
in veins like gold and silver and
chocolate and chalk rle ice cream so you
can be eating the same recipes your
grandmother um used for breakfast lunch
and dinner and she died at 114 and you
got 16 pre-existing conditions you know
diabetes and arthritis and obesity and
high blood pressure and heart disease
and kidney failure uron dialysis and all
this stuff but you're you're getting
insurance is paying for maintaining okay
these issues but it tells you you're
short on nutrition and your bone barrel
is going to suffer your immune system
going to suffer then uh you need to uh
make sure when you get the vaccination
okay
hello oh okay because yeah something
changes here okay so when you get um um
the
vaccinations um the vaccinations don't
kill the virus they just alert your body
to the DNA and RNA from the bad guys
whether it's a virus or bacteria fungus
or yeast and then your body responds
when the bug comes well if you're not
getting nutrition to your bone marrow
you get what's called um um bone marrow
that has gone undergone dysplasia you
don't have any functional bone marrow
that's why people are anemic and they
have to take iron pills and b12 pills
and it doesn't work so they have to
start going to the doctor once a month
for shots and that doesn't work after a
couple of months so they have to get
transfusions for red blood cells and
platelets you don't bleed to death then
after a year or so people get weary of
transfusions every month and so you got
anything else where doctor doctor said
well yeah we can give you a bone marrow
transplant the doctor is going to make
over a million dollars on you treating
the symptoms over and over and over and
over and over because you didn't pay
attention to the details no fried food
no processed Meats no oils no gluten no
weat right on sugar and take the healthy
brain and heart pack one per 100 pounds
of body weight because you have to use
the big hammer here to get all the
nutrients to your bone marrow don't
forget the MSM help your body repair the
bone marrow vitamin D3 to be able to
absorb minerals and repair your bones
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles a month and then don't forget
the collagen we have glucogel I say two
bottles a month of that we'll give you
five of those twice a day and you'll
rebuild your bones you rebuild your bone
marrow and you'll be able to protect
yourself and be able to respond when the
bugs come if you've been vaccinated okay
so there's nothing wrong with
vaccination you have to make that
decision whether or not you're going to
do that regardless either way whether
you're vaccinated or not you still have
to avoid the bad foods and take the
supplements so that your immune system
is going to work so your bone marrows
alive okay so I urge you to contact us
and if you want to know why this is
happening and we had pandemics you know
the first one was um 1918 the Spanish
Flu um that occurred about
let's see 18 years plus 18 is 36 years
after electricity came along nobody was
using wood ashes anymore which had been
our historical use for minerals for the
wood ashes all over the world and
suddenly now nobody's using wood ashes
anymore because they had electricity and
so here we come 36 later 36 years later
we got the Spanish Flu 195,000 Americans
died in October of 1918 in two years we
lost 657 th000 Americans from the
Spanish flu and then came polio and HIV
and the various flu bonanzas and the
next one's going to come we don't change
what we're doing back after these
messages you're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network with your host Dr Joel wallik if
you'd like to talk to Dr Wall call us
toll-free 888
37925 52 on the priority line 831 6851
[Music]
aroma therapy oils have been prized by
ancient cultures for thousands of years
young Jeb's ancient Legacy true aroma
therapy is no exception essential oils
are The Fragrant life Essence from
plants that are gently removed through
the process of steamed distillation
youngevity's ancient Legacy essential
oils are of the purest concentrations
from the most respected and ethical
distillers worldwide many ancient Legacy
oils come directly from families in the
East which have been distilling
essential oils for over 100 years keep
ancient legacy's tea tree oil in your
medicine chest for first aid tea tree
oil is great for soothing the itching
and stinging associated with insect
bites Burns scrapes and other skin areas
itations it's also effective as an
antiseptic to learn more about aroma
therapy and essential oils contact your
local young jeev associate today and
don't forget to ask about business
opportunities if you're looking for a
quality multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself yevi Beyond Tangy
Tangerine a blend of plant- derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this allnatural product contains no
starch wheat or Yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and it's
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
neutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid that is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild yevi
Beyond Tangy Tangerine is available in
1lb canisters and also in 30 count on
the- go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this great
multivitamin and mineral product and
don't forget to ask about the homebased
business
[Music]
opportunity we're back with Dead Doctors
Don't Lie on the zbs radio network Dr
Joel wall here for 95 State we do have
lines open give us a call tollfree 1
18379 2552 again that's
tollfree 18379
2552 and um I again want to remind you
that um we have the book in the CD set
which goes through the history of you
know from wood Ashes to electricity and
all these pandemics the book in the CD
called Hell's Kitchen um you want to
look at the blackchain lives books all
these diseases said to be genetic and
when you look at who are the the most
reported cases of the pandemics all of
them going back to the beginning of time
are the Latinos the black people and the
the indigenous people so why is that
it's not a genetic thing okay it's not a
racial thing so what is it it's their
diet okay it's their diet and just
remember when you look at the states
that have the highest rate of covid
infections and deaths okay the pandemic
um and this goes back to 1918 they have
the highest rate of deaths from the
pandemics regardless of which virus it
is um the states that have the highest
rate of um uh
Latinos and blacks and Indigenous
peoples have the highest rates of death
and infections it's not a racial thing
it's how they eat there's one exception
uh New Mexico has 48 almost 50% Latinos
and they have one of the lowest rates of
um deaths okay from covid and why is
that well their Latinos came from Spain
not Mexico and South America and so
instead of eating um wheat like they do
from Mexico in South America they ate
Spanish rice and corn and free holies
beans and that's why they have such a
low rate of of infections to death even
though they have the highest um rate of
Latinos in their state okay and so when
you look at it you know all the rest are
like um 48% almost 50% Arizona is 31%
North Carolina was only 9% Pennsylvania
7% Georgia is 9% Illinois 177% New
York's 19% Florida's 25% and Texas is
39% and California is 39% okay so you
can kind of see and go by those States
and you'll see the problem it's a it's a
cultural thing it's a diet thing it is
not a racial thing take your 90
essential nutrients and avoid the bad
foods save yourself and save the people
you up okay Doug what Pearls of Wisdom
do you have for us well I've got a story
here headlined adequate uh glutathione
intake has found to boost Liver Health a
study found that glutathione can help
reverse uh liver damage uh associated
with non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
characterized by accumulation of excess
fat in the liver which is if left
untreated can progress into more
aggressive form of liver disease called
non-alcoholic uh
steatosis uh I don't think I said that
right but announced uh is accompanied by
inflammation and eventually uh damages
liver cells and impairing Li liver
function say around a 100 million
individuals in the US have non-alcoholic
fatty liver
disease most of whom are overweight
obese diabetic and have high cholesterol
or high triglyceride levels glutathion
and antioxidant that's compound is
composed of three non-essential amino
acids uh glutamine Glycine and cysteine
and according to uh Oregon State
University Professor Donald B jump says
that the rise in this non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease cases in the America
is due to the American diet which is
high in sugar unhealthy fats and
cholesterol a study by Japanese
researchers found that non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease patient showed
Improvement after taking 300 milligram
of glutathione per day for 4 months
prior to supplementation the patients
underwent a 3month intervention to
improve their diet and physical activity
levels well thank you for that that's
true and so again um you have to
appreciate the liver does 40 different
things it is really a busy organ in the
body does 40 different things and so
when you have to start building up
things like fats and and so forth non
fatty or nonalcoholic fatty liver
disease that tells you something you
don't have the raw materials for all the
biochemistry to work properly and and so
you're getting a buildup of things that
shouldn't be building up and so that's
why we came out with the healthy brain
and heart pack we could call it the
healthy brain and heart and liver and
kidney uh and Lung and brain and thyroid
and adrenal gland and testical and ovary
pack there was two cumbersome so we just
call it the healthy R and heart pack
take one of those for 100 pounds of body
weight and stay away from all the bad
stuff fried foods processed meat oils
and glutens and guess what all those
sort of things go away including fatty
liver you're listening to Dead Doctors
Don't Lie on the zbs radio network with
your host Dr Joel wallik you'd like to
talk to Dr wallik call between noon and
1 Pacific at 831 6851 080 tollfree 888
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you youngevity's
triple treat chocolate is just that an
antioxidant-rich dark chocolate complete
with probiotics to Aid in proper
digestion this allnatural product
contains no preservatives and and for
those with dietary restrictions it's
gluten-free dairyfree glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate taste
fantastic it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an oric value of
16,930 per piece triple treat chocolate
also contains a proprietary blend of
probiotics with over 500 million live
healthy bacteria per 8 g at the time of
manufacturer with 80% reaching the
intestines which is much more than most
live culture yogurts if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities hey if you're like me your
life is hectic you don't know where
you're going to be next between kids and
family and in-laws and work and traffic
and everything else that's driving me
crazy right now my life is insane I bet
your life's insane as well when do we
have time to get every single nutrient
we need to be healthy when well I've got
to tip for you take a product called
pollen burst it's so simple even I can
do it all you have to do is open the
package pour it in water mix it up and
Bam you're ready to go it tastes great
it's not one of those medicine tasting
things it tastes great low in calories
helps curb your appetite gives you
Natural Energy that doesn't let you
crash gives you your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and I got to tell you for a busy
person like me or a busy person like you
we need simple we need good po versus
your answer taste great try it and
you'll feel better call your local
youngevity distributor to find out how
pollen burst can make you feel better
and don't forget to ask about home-based
business
opportunities you've if your doctor is
telling you that you can get all the
nutrients you need to stay healthy well
that's just wrong Dr Joel wallik has
identified 90 essential nutrients that
the human body needs to thrive crops
only need three nutrients to thrive so
so where does your doctor think the
other 87 nutrients come from they don't
so if you're not supplementing you're
starving your body longevities Beyond
Tangy Tangerine will get you a long way
down the road to getting those 90
essential nutrients Beyond Tangy
Tangerine contains plant- derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
Beyond Tangy Tangerine is a balanced and
complete daily supplement so if you want
to give your body the the nutrients it
needs order Beyond Tangy Tangerine today
contact your local youngevity associate
to order this product and don't forget
to ask about homebased business
[Music]
opportunities we're back with Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the zbs radio
network Dr Joel wall care for young 95
Crusade we do have lines open give us a
call tollfree one8 379 2552 again that's
toll-f free8 379
2552 and don't forget if you're going to
be exercising okay whether it's in your
home or a gym because you're opening
everything up and everybody's man have
been cooped up I need to exercise blah
blah blah BL blah and um you want to be
sure you're taking your 90 essential
nutrients you want to take a rebound or
Sport strink with 100 nutrients and it's
got 75 minerals in there okay a theor
Ratliff um Evander Holyfield Virgil
Akens let's see here people like Pat
Boon um Drew Pearson I could go on and
on and on all these famous people and
athletes and so forth who do exercise
and of course I guess Pat Boon is you
know playing in the in the seniors
League the basketball team he's 82 years
old okay um and because of our products
okay um theatl lost his contract with
the Atlanta Hawks to make a long story
short we rebuilt him came up with the
rebound for him the healthy Bon and
Joint pack and he got a $35 million
contract you're think he's happy well
he's on he's on the label of our rebound
product chry
there yep I'm here I'm here I'm here
okay dear now you've seen people who
exercise and don't take supplements what
happens to them they die because they
run out of energy they run out of uh
nutrients they run on EMP yeah there's
there Argan stop functioning okay and so
what would you recommend as far as a
tool what would you have them Listen to
As I'll give you a hint there's two CDs
that tell people what to do if they're
going to exercise and get on the 90
cents of nutrients get on the healthy
Bone and Joint pack take the rebound
what what two CS would you have somebody
listen to if they're going to exercise
dead athletes don't
lie no that's true that's one what's the
other one I just get on the
exercise without yeah exercise without
supplementation is
suicide good yeah yeah those two things
and you need to have kids who want to
exercise well you know the coach says I
can just eat well and get everything I
need no you have to do a lot more than
that otherwise you wind up dying young I
think so far this year they had 500,000
Kids In America 500,000 Kids In America
di this hypertrophy cardiopathy heart
disease okay a sudden heart death of
these young kids who are
athletes and Char you know we you we and
I've been working on this for a long
time don't tell them what the nutrient
is okay because I don't want to because
there's five co-actors you need to have
so you need that one nutrient and the
five
co-actors but that's in our um healthy
brain and heart pack it's in our rebound
okay and so you're you're about how
you're just sh of 80 years old how much
rebound do you drink every day well well
I I tried to drink it one can a day they
made the cans a lot bigger so it takes
me longer to drink it yeah well these to
be 8 O cans and now they're 12 O cans
yeah and so because people want they
wanted more and so yeah and of course we
have coffee we have tea we have all kind
of stuff we we have our own um
plantations we grow our own coffee
plants and our own tea plants and so
forth we fertilize them with our Bloomin
minerals fertilizer with 75 minerals in
it so our coffee our tea and our
rebounders for string is a lot different
than Red Bull and folders
okay and you know Char sounds like she's
a 40y old she looks like she's a 22y old
we'll be back after these messages
you're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the zbs radio network with your
host Dr Joel wallik if you'd like to
talk to Dr wallet call us tollfree 888
37925 52 on the priority line 831 6851
[Music]
you've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr Joel wallik help many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr Wall if
you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself longevities Beyond Tangy
Tangerine a blend of plant-derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this allnatural product contains no
starch wheat or Yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and it's
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
Nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild
longevities Beyond Tangy Tangerine is
available in one lb canisters and also
in 30 count on the-go Stick packs
contact your local youngevity associate
and get this great multivitamin and
mineral product and don't forget to ask
about the homebased business
opportunity in 1901 a Woman by the name
of Annie Taylor climbed into a barrel so
that she could ride that Barrel over
Niagara Falls the first person to do so
the reason for her crazy Endeavor she
was struggling to make NS meet and she
was hoping for Fame and Financial
Security it's Ryan from United Faith
mortgage a Faith and Family Mortgage
team that tries to improve your
financial Outlook without having to ship
you over a 170t waterfall our mortgage
team happens to be in arm of a bigger
company who is a direct lender which
means our company gets to use its own
money and make its own decisions within
its own walls there's no middleman this
Advantage often allows us to get you a
better rate which can save you monthly
and lifelong money through a refinance
or help you with a Cash out refinance
cashing out some of your home's Equity
to to use for life we are United Faith
mortgage United Faith mortgage is a DBA
United mortgage cor 25 M Park M New York
Li mortgage Banker for all licensing
information go anal consumer access or
corporate analist number 1335 R analist
number 65233 Equal Housing lender licens
in Alaska Hawaii Georgia Massachusetts
North Dakota South Dakota or Utah if
you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product grab
yourself longevities Beyond Tangy
Tangerine a blend of plant-derived
minerals combined with vitamins amino
acids and other beneficial nutrients
this all natural product contains no
starch wheat or Yeast with no artificial
sweeteners or preservatives and it's
glycemic friendly each scoop of the
Nutra crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients it starts out as a
liquid then is freeze dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop so if you want to get your hands
on a quality nutritional supplement
designed to give the body the raw
materials it needs to rebuild
longevities Beyond Tangy Tangerine is
available in 1B canisters and also in
30C count on the-go Stick packs contact
your local youngevity associate and get
this great multivitamin and mineral
product and don't forget to ask about
the homebased business
[Music]
opportunity we're back with Dead Doctors
Don't line the zbs radio network Dr Joel
wall here for Youngy 95 Crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll
free8 379 2552 again that's toll free8
2552 and um the age thing of course
people dying of this pandemic it goes by
age when you look at a a three-year-old
okay their a their um death rate uh is
really weird it's um in kids under age
three it's
0.06% die 18 to 44 is 3.9% die 45 to 64
is 22% die 65 to 74 25% die and 75 and
above 48% die okay why is that well
because three year olds have only been
eating gluten for three years 20 years
olds have only been eating gluten for
like 18 years maybe and a 75y old has
been eaten gluten for 72 years okay your
intestines are dead and they don't
supplement and that's why why the older
people have a much harder time with the
pandemic virus than a younger person get
off the gluten take your 90 take a
rebound and save yourself okay Doug
let's go to callar all right let's head
to California and Nani you're on with Dr
wallik oh Nani you're on the air oh hi
Dr W thank you for taking my call yes
ma'am okay here here's my problem I had
a mitro valve replacement surgery 5
years ago and last year about April I
wasn't feeling well so they scheduled me
an echo in November echo
cardiogram and they found out my
ejection fraction was only 15 to 18 so
they thought there was a blockage so I
did an angiogram and there was no
blockage so the
cardiologist uh put me on entresto for
three months and then I just did another
echogram in in MH uh
February and it didn't help my ejection
okay I got it I okay okay stop stop okay
now do you have any other issues any
high blood pressure
diabetes I have high blood pressure and
I have thyroid
Hashimoto okay I've had that you still
okay you still have okay you still have
your thyroid they didn't remove it no
okay do you have any ringing in your
ears any tone you know that noise
no okay do you have any balance
problems yes sometimes okay now do you
have any numbness or tingling in your
hands or fingers or
arms
yes okay and how much do you
away uh
177 and how tall
57 okay 57 for a girl I like to see away
140 150 might have to lose about 25
pounds okay so Charmaine what would you
do here for
Noni um she's um got high blood pressure
she's has an enlarged heart which the
that makes the valves or micro valve
leaves don't meet because as the heart
gets bigger the valve leaves don't grow
and so you know they're not meant for a
bigger hole like that so that's why and
the doctors are looking for other things
they don't they forget that when the
heart gets bigger the valves don't meet
properly so she got enlarged heart she's
got high BL pressure thyroid issues and
she's about 25 lbs overweight what would
you do for her well again no wheat
barley Ry oats no fried foods no burnt
animal fat and no oils of any kind and
then I would get around two healthy
brain and heart packs because of her
weight and ultimate daily classic she
should get at least two bottles of that
and she needs some oceans gold vitamin
D3 for absorption boy that's important I
tell you vitamin D3 and uh
I would get around some MSM too yeah for
the osteoporosis of the skull you get an
A+ deer call us every couple of weeks
only because you're going to see a huge
benefit get rid of the bad stuff take
that supplement program and you'll lose
weight just by getting off all the bad
foods we'll be back after these messages
and that does open a line if you'd like
to talk to Dr wallet call between noon
and 1 Pacific at 831 6851 080 tollfree
[Music]
[Applause]
two hi register farmis Ben fuches here
I've been studying healthy bodies for 35
years and what I've got to tell you may
shock and surprise you but if you listen
up it may change your life I've been
seeing a lot of commercials for cleanser
toner treatment Triad the brainchild of
two Stanford train dermatologists they
came up with the idea in the early '90s
and the rest made acne medication
history and if you've seen the
commercials you know why they're very
compelling from movie star endorsements
to regular teen testimonials make a
convincing appeal that all you have to
do is use their products and your
blemishes will be banished for good the
active ingredient is called benzo
peroxide it kills acne bacteria and it
also helps remove excess and accumulated
pore clogging skin cells and their
debris as well as Skin oils this creates
a smoother look to the skin and improves
its appearance its anti-inflammatory
effects may also support skin healing
vensel peroxide is also a poison to
cells and it can ultimately kill them
given its well-known toxicity the FDA
limits the use of benil peroxide to 5
and 10% and acne blemishes which are
really nothing more than the end result
of cell chemistry gone nuts is not
really a drug or medication issue anyway
the typical acne blemish is caused by
the acne blemishes messed up
biochemistry stress and growth hormones
are involved too insulin and blood sugar
and so is the digestive system
nutritional deficiencies don't help and
that's pretty much it stay stay away
from foods that cause digestive distress
and stay away from foods that mess up
your blood sugar chemistry use lots of
electrolytes B vitamins Rich amounts of
veggies and veggie juices those can also
help and so can nutritional supplements
like zinc selenium vitamin A and
essential fatty acids among others
pharmac's Ben here urging you to go to
ksco health.com to order Beyond Tangy
Tangerine the Healthy Start pack and
other nutritional supplements that I
personally use and recommend you can
purchase these premium quality products
at wholesale prices online at Koh
health.com that's kco health.com I'm a
pharmacist that believes that staying
healthy and strong is not only about
medicine it's about giving your body the
raw materials it needs to do its work go
to ksco health.com make sure you check
out the cool videos too at ksco
health.com that's ksco
[Music]
[Applause]
health.com we're back with Dead Doctors
Don't line the zbs trader Network Dr
Joel wall here for young divy 95 Crusade
we do have audence open give us call
toll-free 1p8 379 2552 again that's
toll-f free8 379 2552 and just a quick
comparison here so you when we talk
about get off the bad foods is it really
is it really that important let's look
at Florida versus Taiwan both of them
have a little over 22 million people um
Florida as of this morning had
1,900 um 11,000 infections Taiwan has
less than a thousand infections 9
55 um Florida has 31,000 dead and Taiwan
has nine dead just nine not not 900 not
9,000 nine dead so what's the DraStic
difference between 31,000 dead and Nine
Dead 1. n see 1, 91,000 infections
versus a thousand what's the difference
well Florida 40 50 60% depending what
county you're looking at are Latinos
blacks and Indigenous peoples all of
whom eat wheat barley R oats whereas
Taiwan they live on rice sweet potatoes
beans corn and seaweed huh there you go
the seaweed is where they're getting all
their tra merals to make their bone
marrow happy soing can defend themselves
against the pandemic virus okay Doug
let's go to callers all right let's head
to Georgia and Sasha you're on with Dr
wallik oh Sasha you're on the air hi hi
um I'm 18 years old mom weigh 120 129
lbs and I'm 5'4 and I I completely lost
Vision in my left eye and I had went to
the doctor for and they said it was
optic neuritis then I went to a
specialist and they said it might be
atrophy and then like a week or two ago
I'm starting to lose slowly lose vision
in my right eye and I've been on the
healthy I'm sure been on healthy I've
been on the healthy brain um the healthy
brain and heart pack for about two weeks
along with imortalium and vision effects
okay very good now do you have any have
you had any ringing in your ears any
ttis or ringing in the
ears oh yes okay the balance as well you
do have a balance problem okay uh are
you an
athlete oh yeah okay what sports you
play s swimer okay now um do you have
any skin problems any eima dermatitis or
psoriasis no hello okay uh do you have
any botle problems constipation diarrhea
a bow syndrome celiac disease anything
like
that no okay now Charmaine are you there
I'm here she's got osteoporosis of the
skull well wait a minute she's only 18
years old how can that be doesn't matter
it doesn't
matter that's part of the eye problem
probably too well yeah it is a part of
the eye problem because you get what's
called optic nerve atrophy as the skull
you get out your approach of the skull
the skull gets bigger and I want
everybody to get that book it's all in
your head and it goes into the 25
different diseases including this
gradual blindness that happens
regardless of Ages you point out Char
age is not an issue no okay okay so go
to
www.dj wallet.com and get that book it's
all in your head and so what would you
give her she's already starting to take
some stuff but what would you give her
specifically because she's got ringing
in the ears got Bal got a yeah for her
issue I'd get her on a healthy um uh
Bone and Joint pack and I would add that
MSM to it and I would also add the utive
to it what the heck it can't hurt and uh
she can't have any Wheat barley Ry or
oats no fried foods no oils and no burnt
animal fat very important and vitamin D3
for absorption okay any plus here and
what about selenium what about our
selenium with the five oh yeah I would
defin because that's for that helps for
macular degeneration and all kinds of
stuff yeah okay so yeah she can take
three of those twice maybe two BS a
month and then stay away from all the
bad foods if you would Sasha okay and
then give us a call every couple of
weeks because your testimony is going to
help thousands of people especially
younger people who think they can't get
these problem because they're younger
osteoprosis of the skull is not
something that just happens in people
who are over 70 years old and ladies
have 10 kids no no babies can be born
without a prosis skull and um it's one
of those things where you have to stay
away from the bad foods fried foods
process Meats oils gluten wheat brother
R know got to stay away from them
forever and being your age you can
recover extremely quickly so do call us
every couple of weeks we'll walk you
through this you are going to have a
great testimony and just remember
exercise without supplementation of
suicide and exercise or excuse me dead
athletes don't lie we want you to be one
of the live athletes and tell the story
over and over and over okay Doug let's
go to callers all right let's head to
South Carolina and James you're on with
Dr wallik James you're on the air how
can we help you sir yes sir how you
doing Dr okay how can we help you I'm
doing fine how can we help you okay my
mother my mother got uh she had Co she
had Co and she went to the heart thr and
she come back her toes got black and
they swelling up and don't have no
circulation in them and they want to
okay okay all our
toes no just one of the big toe I
believe okay so it's just in one foot
yeah one leg right leg okay okay does
she have any other issues any highight
pressure diabetes yeah yeah all of that
she have all of that okay okay and so
how much does she weigh how big a girl
is she I think she about 22
2240 she about
five okay 5'6 okay so what would you do
for this lady okay she's 5'6 okay 240
lbs and you say she's how old I think
she about she about 79
79 okay so she's about your age Chaine
79 years old she got high blood pressure
diabetes and she's got one toe on one
foot that uh is um maybe losing some
circulation and so is changing color and
swelling and everything like that what
would you do for her first of all she's
got to get on a good diet no wheat
barley Ry or oats no oils of any kind no
fried foods and no burnt animal fat then
to save m she because of her weight she
needs two packs I would get her one
healthy uh brain and heart pack and one
healthy blood sugar pack and then I
would add to it the ultimate daily
classic vitamin D3 for absorption which
is very
important and MSM
obviously and
um what would you do for a
diabetes Well the blood the healthy
blood sugar pack will take care of a lot
of that but she could get an extra
bottle of sweeties and and gly yeah I'd
have her get an extra bottle yeah you're
right there I'd have her get an extra
bottle because she's got so many things
going on here I'd have get two bottles
of that ultimate daily classic tablets
which you pointed out very nicely so you
can take three of those twice a day
that'll support healthy blood pressure
and healthy blood flow uh including the
toes okay and so i' I'd not rush to go
get her toes amputated I would go to
another um orthopic surgeon and and find
out what their opinion is um and um
first question on the phone be sure to
ask the secretary when you make the
appointment for your mom um does this
does this orthopedic surgeon have kids
in college in his tuition do okay
because you don't want to take your mom
to somebody like that because he's going
to find all kinds of things to do just
so he can get tuition money for the kids
okay and so it's one of those deals
where what would you what would you
recommend sh to put on that toe U to to
relieve the discomfort and swelling you
put it you know topically well colloidal
silver for one thing would help also
internally she can take the um uh o oxy
body Cherry Berry that would help it too
okay because that increases the oxygen
in your blood immediately and so what
would you have her take also Orly to
deal with the
infection well Orly she could take
killer biotic I would yeah yeah killer
biotic and also the the the cidal silver
yep I put two Dr yeah droppers full
under her tongue 30 minutes for each
meal and two droppers full under her
tongue 30 minutes for bedtime and the
Cal silver it was the antibiotic of of
thousands of years until the 1930s when
they patented penicillin and doctors
dumped after thousands of years the
perfect antioxidant doctors dumped
collidal silver because you could get it
from a feed store okay or health food
store but you had to go to the doctor to
get a prescription of the penicillin be
back after these messages you're
listening to Dead Doctors Don't Lie on
the zbs radio network with your host Dr
Joel wallik if you'd like to talk to Dr
Wall call between noon and one Pacific
at 888-
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
earth's oceans we do know that the
oceans and seas are still abundant with
life and life- sustaining nutrients many
cultures have long believed in the
life-giving properties of plants and sea
life harvested from the oceans young
Jeb's oceans gold is a proprietary blend
of seaweeds algae mosses kelp sea
cucumbers and sea minerals as well as
co-enzyme Q10 calcium and iron all
designed to help support healthy thyroid
function regular heartbeat normal weight
mood stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage of life syst staining
nutrients from the Earth's oceans with
youngevity oceans gold if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about homebased business
opportunities if weight loss is your
goal try youngevity slender FX keto
caramel weight management bars and Shake
designed to enhance any low carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing and filling protein dieters
need without unhealthy excess carbs a
keto diet known for its low carb intake
pushing the body to produce ketones from
fat used as energy a state known as
ketosis by using fat not carbohydrates
as fuel in this metabolic State a keto
diet supports and promotes healthy
weight management for Optimal Health
with this system you should be able to
lose one to 2 lbs each
day so what are you waiting for start
helping people today with your own
homebased
business you if weight loss is your goal
try youngevity slender FX keto caramel
weight management bars and Shake
designed to enhance any low carbohydrate
or low glycemic diet by supplying the
energizing and filling protein dieters
need without unhealthy excess carbs a
keto diet known for its low carb intake
pushing the body to produce ketones from
fat used as energy a state known as
ketosis by using fat not carbohydrates
as fuel in this metabolic State a keto
diet supports and promotes healthy
weight management for Optimal Health
with this system you should be able to
lose one to 2 lbs each
day so what are you waiting for start
helping people today with your own
homebased
business we're back with Dead Doctors
Don't Lie on the zbs radio network Dr
Joel wall care 958 and Doug let's go to
callers all right let's head to new
Jersey and Jeff you're on with Dr wallik
hello Jeff you're on the air how can we
help you hey Doc I'm a big fan I've been
using the healthy body start pack for
about six seven years now um what
happened had had an injury I basically
um went February 3rd went sleigh riding
and uh we were kind of uh standing up on
our sleds kind of like snowboarding
going down the hill my knee fell down no
big deal get back up going on happens
all the time but then at the end of the
day I fell my knee experienced like a
valgus force and so the um I had a black
and blue mark on the inner side of my
knee and on my right knee and I I just
had a really bad limping really bad it
hurt a lot and I I believe I've probably
torn my
MCL and I it feels really bad because
it's still still okay stop okay okay
stop have you gone to a chiropractor or
an arch Fe surgeon or
anybody no I haven't gone to anyone cuz
I I read that uh you know you can get an
MRI and then there really is no
treatment after that I mean arthoscopy
only leaves you with more osteoarthritis
yeah okay now how old are you sir uh I'm
a 42 year old 160 pound male at
5'7 okay any other issues H pressure
diabetes
arthritis no I I've been try I've been
struggling to cut down my wheat intake I
would say in 2019 I've pretty much cut
like 99% of my wheat intake going the
right directions okay we only have a
moment here so Charmaine what would you
do for Jeff he has a traumatic injury on
his right knee and um um he has
discomfort and some swelling and so what
would you do for
him well I don't know what he's taking
now but for that I would he's 160 pounds
right right I would take two healthy uh
Bone and Joint packs you know for that
and I would take a uh ultimate uh
vitamin D3 of course MSM three those
twice it MSM I would go ahead with three
three times it every two BS a month to
speed that healing up and what would you
do for Himel five of those twice a day
there two botes a month in the capsules
what would you give him for pain well he
could put some trauma oil into the CM
cream and use that
topically
okay and uh all right and he can also
take some fucoid Z for the
injury okay very good choice okay so
that's kind of our you know kind of
offerings there Jeff and Char gave you a
good plan and so if you would if you'd
call us every couple of weeks 42 years
old um if you can put weight on that
foot and leg uh the odds are you don't
have a fracture in there if it's swollen
um you might want to get one of those
wraps from a medical device Placer or a
pharmacy you know a stretchy kind of um
joint wrap or something like that so
support it and um uh if you have a
walker or something like that that'll
help too but take these supplements stay
away from the bad food maximize
absorption and call us every two weeks
because your story is quite common for
middle-aged people 35 to 55 kind of
thing and so you're going to have a
great testimony to share with everybody
we really appreciate you sharing your
story and we appreciate you you know
sharing I'm sure with your family and
your neighbors and your work workmates
you're still working if you're 42 years
old and um um it's one of those things
where um oftentimes we get a lot of
young people we get a lot of older
people but middle-aged people don't seem
to contact as much but we're glad you're
doing it because you're going to have
such a great story to share with so many
people uh because it's not uncommon and
just the fact that at your age 42 years
old you felt good enough you were
snowboarding down the hill standing up
on it snowboard like you're skiing down
the hill and um uh that's uh quite
impressive so we applaud you and we just
beg you to you know kind of go the
direction that sharp pointed out and
please do call us every couple of weeks
with a status report and um you know
we'll be happy to walk through this with
you you're gonna have a great testimony
and let's see here how much time we got
here Doug got about 30 seconds 30
seconds I'm going to remind everybody if
you want to learn what to do for
yourself and the people you love go to
www.dj wall.com
www.dj wall.com we deal with over 600
different diseases we've had products
for over 600 different diseases we've
been doing this for over 50 years and um
it's one of those things where you
cannot go wrong by at least
participating in your own health don't
just throw it all to a doctor
participate and you'll be benefited very
well by participating in your own health
well thank you so much Charmaine super
job as usual thank you Doug super job as
usual God bless each and every one of
you God bless our troops God bless our
Navy Seals God bless the American flag
God bless the national anthem and God
Bless
[Music]
America